hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one-night-stand the game
uh Ryan and Matt actually recommended
this one to me and it's interesting
because this isn't normally the type of
game that I would play even though I
played netflix and chill' the game so I
guess I don't have any standards on
anything but they said it was
interesting and I'm gonna go into it not
expecting much and then seeing where it
takes from there my head oh my stomach
huh I feel like crap okay last night
what happened oh so oh this isn't oh
okay this isn't a dating ah I got it got
it okay drink lots of drink happened
I can drink I'll die ah what's that
noise I don't know you tell me bro your
phone I did yes mm my phone where is my
phone what is this Dora the explora can
you find phone I have to imagine that
it's this got it I also don't have any
glasses cuz apparently I can't see
anything might what the hell happened to
you lost no I have no idea but thanks a
lot for waking me up angry face 5%
battery remaining crap my phone is about
to die and my eyes are still blurry
better plug it in before the battery
runs out okay nope can't plug my phone
into that what you try to stick it up
your bud why or that okay ah my phone
charger has to be around here somewhere
maybe not whoa oh wait I don't recognize
this bedside table this is in my room is
that a condom wrapper on the floor kids
shut your eyes my clothes they're all
over the floor am i me I'm completely
naked oh [ __ ] that never happens
oh um oh hi hello how are you oh let me
just shout into your back Oh
I guess I got lucky last night this must
be her room I hope this is our room it
would be an even more bizarre scenario
if not but who is she
good question all the girls were so
pissed off I can't believe our ditched
Mod date so you could just bail on us
[ __ ] sounds like drunk me was up to no
good last night hate to let my mates
down but I guess my mind must have been
elsewhere so I honestly don't know what
happened to me last night but I guess
but guess what I pulled
what the hell does that mean yeah that
should shut him up
yeah bruh could she be one of the girls
from last night that Gary was talking
about even if she was I don't know
anything about her
I can't even remember her name [ __ ] I
really can't remember anything about
happened last night
I don't even know where the hell I am
right now oh this hangover isn't helping
Oh always the best nights when you drink
so much you can't even remember any of
the fun you had
[ __ ] one drink and you're off
betting women you're gonna need a better
excuse for ditching all your mates than
that Gary doesn't believe me he sounds
pretty pissed off huh that's weird
if Gary's not gonna take my word for it
I could take a sneaky picture that would
shut him up huh
that seems like a very morally bad thing
to do ha I wonder if I should take the
high road and sneak in picture of this
naked lady or just tell Gary to shut the
[ __ ] up
I'm not gonna take the picture that'd
just be creepy and weird and this game
is already slightly creepy oh [ __ ] my
phone's dead anyway what should I do
ahh wake her up I guess why not that's
what I do I guess Hey
who the hell are you why are you in your
bed I mean me I don't know I need
answers and I need them now Hey Oh what
the did she just throw the duvet over me
and how do I have the current
wherewithal don't know though term duvet
it can differentiate a duvet
from a blanket she's gone it was a ghost
I slept with a ghost maybe she's a
little freaked out about all this I know
I am [ __ ]
Irie didn't really get a good look of
her considering the duvet on my face
maybe she wants me to leave huh uh-oh
hello
this must be her wallet I really
shouldn't be looking through this but
then again this might contain some
useful information about her driver's
license an ID card again with the creepy
invasions privacy I'm gonna err on the
side of caution I'll just ask her when
she freaking says hi to me yeah romance
no eyes of embrace it sounds intriguing
intriguing maybe I should give this a
read aha I think we found the cause of
his hangover honey I don't normally
drink wine especially red gets drunk me
doesn't care what he's pouring in the
tank a real hablas fare let's hare raah
sounds fancy it's half empty hello hi oh
hello oh hey duh how you doing are you
okay you okay I don't know yeah I'm
sorry for dashing out of the room like
that I hope I didn't freak you out or
anything well I was only slightly
perturbed by the duvet on my face it's
okay I was just a little shocked when I
was suddenly smothered by the do they I
want to emphasize how fancy I am sorry
as soon as I woke up I really just
really needed - to the bathroom uh I'd
rather not go into it if it's okay with
you no I want to talk about this oh to
share everything with each other so have
you been awake long not really my phone
woke me up I wonder what the noise one
who woke me up - oh sorry oh sure she
would have noticed if I could have taken
a picture her chunk right in her back I
don't worry about it
I know you're reading eyes of embrace ha
ha ha
you found one of my vices um yeah I'd
recommend this by another student
there's pretty trashy so far call me
old-fashioned but I prefer stuff by
Austin and bran
to this I don't know if bronze is I
think I know Austin I'll probably keep
reading it though really even though
you're not enjoying it yeah of course
I'd hate to leave a book half read I
always see them through to the end no
matter how trashy they are this is a
little awkward
I should ask something um hangover do
you have a hangover yeah just a little
one I mostly just feel nauseous after a
night out like that what about you
you don't look too great no I'm [ __ ]
up I feel awful
I feel sick I feel a little bit sick I'm
not surprised you'd already had it quite
a few drinks before we met last night is
that so Gary said I only had one drink
before mmm is there anything I can get
you to make you feel better
uh coffee cup of coffee sure this seems
like such normal life this is bizarre
okay that went well she seems nice I
guess she seems nice I'm no closer to
finding out what happened last night did
happen last night
ah a condom wrapper thank goodness we
took precautions
well this one mystery wrapped up okay
pile of magazines some music gaming
Magda near some of the articles sound
pretty interesting see karamja James odd
stains ripping they're good for another
day or two after they like me they're
good for another month to a year I need
to find my boxes hello again hey how are
you old enough I have no idea uh yeah
fine well I hope this helps
Thanks smells good well it's not
Starbucks but hopefully it'll help ship
that hangover it's delicious
thank you human see you have your genes
there oh yeah I thought I'd pick them up
I see you know you shouldn't have
spoiled me with that fancy bottle of
wine fancy bottle of wine that's not a
fancy bottle of wine
no sorry to disappoint you I say fancy
stuff for special occasions not like you
I want to emphasize
you're not special in any way we didn't
drink that last night that's just a
bottle I keep by my bedside you know for
studying uh
looks like I can't blame this hangover
on the wine then feels awkward again I
should really ask her about last night
she must know something so that was
quite a night huh yeah it was all right
by the way Thanks huh last night I was
feeling pretty down
I always brushed off the idea of meeting
up with a stranger through a dating app
Oh huh and then having the guy bail on
me in the middle of the date huh what an
[ __ ]
what okay I'm ready to jump into that
taxi go home and shut myself in for days
I'm really glad you showed up you bought
me a drink you listened to me and it
cheered me up
I guess the night turned around thanks
to you so she got stood up
and I stepped in maybe this explains why
I damson huh what okay huh oh I'm sorry
it's okay they're just a little pissed
with me this morning I didn't even
realize you were there with friends you
didn't mention anything about them at
all really I was in a bar with Gary and
a couple other people I think huh you
think well hang on do you even remember
my name
no no I don't oh my god this is
humiliating
why is is not my fault I don't know what
the hell happened so you don't remember
anything let's see
now I really know I honestly don't
remember a goddamn thing but really yeah
you must be pretty confused then yes I
am I'll fill you in on what I know we
met around 11:00 at the bar at paradox
you'd had a few drinks but you didn't
seem too drunk you bought me a drink and
we found a secluded spot to Chad
we chatted for ages without being
interrupted even at a bar as loud as
paradox at the end of the night we both
had quite a few drinks neither of us
were in a state to make good decisions
when the
taxi arrived we both jumped in and I
guess we ended up here and then and then
I'm not gonna tell you all about that
well I was part of it that's everything
I can recall I don't know anything that
happened leading up to that sorry no
it's fine thanks for helping me fill in
the blanks still doesn't answer a few
questions listen about last night yeah
going out meeting a total stranger and
bringing them here home this isn't
something I normally do in fact I've
never done this before she's never had a
one-night stand before have you ever
done anything like this well me
personally no but what do I say here no
I mean I don't know this guy's life why
would I no no I've not that's reassuring
it makes me feel a little bit less
uncomfortable about the whole thing I
guess what I'm trying to say is I don't
want this to be typical I mean you're
still here you didn't sneak out before I
woke up or whilst I was out of the room
I don't know
clearly you were nice to me last night
part of me thought you'd want to leave
as soon as you woke up but you're still
here I mean that in a good way of course
she's happy that I'm still here
I guess I've managed to make a good
impression all things considered listen
we didn't really get to know each other
that well last night I ranted about my
date life in life troubles I've talked
enough about me
tell me about you well considering I
don't really remember anything
apparently uh tell me something about
you again I don't I don't know this guy
where would I be any position disease
thing I knows might sound strange but if
we get to know each other a little
better then maybe this could be
different different like maybe this
doesn't have to be as weird as just two
strangers hooking up I don't know sure I
guess which I tell her about myself uh
my personality my friends my hobbies my
friends you were pissed at me and my
personality which at this point is
probably equivalent to a stump I'll talk
about my hobbies I guess I start with
little oh you were about to talk about
yourself let me throw up a little bit
sorry wait here I'll be right back
she's gone a strange turn pale as soon
as I opened my mouth but just just me
even trying to talk and make a clear
sentence sick endure oh this
relationship is not gonna work find
anything more about her well there's my
boxers oh that's my shirt stinks of
sweat and smoke you know I'd rather oh
it's all I've got so no choice there's a
picture of her with someone else looks
pretty old girls with some guy maybe
he's a friend or a relative of hers oh
good it's a mirror how do I look like
crap I may feel like crap but I've
certainly seen worse I shoulda looked at
the guitar cuz I would have told me
something about her hey you okay
not really sorry I just felt really sick
all the sudden oh no she's breaking oh
God say what should I do offer to help
can I get you anything
thanks but I think I just need some rest
I hate to be rude but I'd like to be
alone now oh okay are you sure yes
please don't take it the wrong way
you've been a real gent even this
morning when you could have just easily
left sorry to cut this short I just need
to get some rest okay
oh I quickly gravely I still can't find
my underwear what the hell okay I've got
all my stuff cool she's gonna chill this
bed for a little bit to a jolt on out of
here there's a bus station down the road
or so you should be able to get home
from there
Thanks listen don't take this the wrong
way you've been real nice this whole
time I'm grateful for that
let's see I want to see again I guess I
really like you from the 10 minutes
we've talked to each other pay for
things end like this
can I see you again listen you seem like
a nice guy and I really appreciate that
you didn't run out of here as soon as
you got up but I'm sure some people find
something deep in a one-night stand but
I'm sorry I just don't think there's
anything good for us here oh okay
I mean we're just meant to go our
separate ways right uh sure from me girl
sees you the front door waves you
goodbye
you didn't expect things stand up this
way she really seemed like a nice girl
you walk out on the street trying to
find a way home
White Hall isn't gonna played out well
what did I do
huh what did I do wrong
what it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't save
aah oh my god I'm going in again there's
so weird cuz it's like a slice of
reality you know it's just a piece of
normal human experiences which is
bizarre it's game high a really nice I'm
grateful for that
can we be friends
yeah I think so don't get me wrong I
don't mean friends with benefits or
anything like that but you made me feel
better in a moment of need and I'm
grateful for that
so yeah let's be friends okay that's
another way that could give her your
contact details though you still don't
find out her name she sees you the front
door gives you a hug smile she really is
a nice girl after all you walk out on
the street head to nearby bus station
she says
would you help me charge your phone and
discover a message from an unknown
number Thanks X ok that's literally like
the only thing that I did differently
now let's get that app laid out I don't
really know what any interesting subject
bizarre admittedly very bizarre but an
interesting take on like what I said
before like a slice of reality like this
is an occurrence it's not a common
occurrence but it's an occurrence and
there's a lot of different ways that you
could take it I suppose that more than
anything could be a little slice of a
game so I'll leave the rest up to you
guys to discover you could be one way or
another in this game you could treat the
scenario with any different number of
variables so try to find it out for
yourself so I guess that's it so thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you Ryan to Matt for suggesting it and I
don't know if I missed something let me
know in the comments below and let me
know what you think of this a weird
experience in the comments as well
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
I'll do my best ah you're joking right
joking here now I don't expect the UPS
level sail directly into my mouth I
can't expect to me work for my me what